so after a lot of speculation new york
city's incoming mayor eric adams
announced that he is keeping de blasio's
private sector vaccine mandate which
means that basically anyone working in
new york city needs to be vaccinated and
that's not all his team brought us this
new year's eve message
we'll also study the need for what we're
calling the up-to-date mandate which
would require new yorkers to have their
booster shots under the vaccine mandates
currently in place
so team adams must have not gotten the
message that you can still get coveted
even if you're vaccinated
new york city doesn't report numbers on
breakthrough cases i'm sure that's just
an oversight but we know they're
happening let's take a look at
massachusetts whose population is just
slightly smaller than new york city in
the last week alone 44 of all total
cases were from people who have already
been vaccinated
joining me now is dr harvey risch yale
school of medicine professor and
epidemiologist and dr marty mccary
professor at the john hopkins school of
medicine and the author of the price we
pay
dr rish we see eric adams is now saying
he's going to keep this vaccine mandate
in the city but new york is getting
crushed we saw 74 000 cases today alone
new york city saw the biggest day of
cases than any major city in the entire
world yet we have a state that has mask
mandates we have a city of new york that
has a vaccine passport you got to be
vaccinated just go to restaurant or you
know to basically live among society at
this point why would any city why would
any business why would any ver
university be forcing a vaccine that
doesn't stop the spread of covid
well to be frank we ain't seen nothing
yet
that this omicron virus we're likely to
see at the beginning of next week or by
tuesday or wednesday a million cases per
day in the united states this is where
it's going this is not frightening this
is good news because it's generating a
lot of population immunity we should not
be looking at the cases and
unfortunately the health commissioner in
new york city is still mired in the past
looking at case numbers he should be
looking at hospitalizations and
mortality from omicron that's what tells
you what to do about policy moving
forward and he's not doing that
you know dr mccary now that we are
starting to see i mean look we're seeing
so many people get coveted at this point
do you think the government will be
forced to recognize not natural immunity
well the public is smart enough to
realize that you can't not ignore it
indefinitely why hasn't the government
though
there's 141 studies at this point any
more research is not going to convince
them they clearly have an entrenched
political interest and it to them it
threatens the vaccinate everybody
message and that's the bottom line and i
think that's eventually where there's
going to be so much pushback they're
going to have to at some point just
recognize that
people are not going to tolerate
dishonesty in science
you know but dr rich to marty mccary's
point you know
why do we have this push to get the
vaccine when it's clearly not stopping
the spread of covid
well at some point we thought that it
might but that is long in the past
already there's so much evidence around
the world that it doesn't and our own
evidence that it doesn't that we have to
reevaluate but we have entrenched
interests the whole this whole pandemic
was sold to us as wait for the vaccines
the vaccines will cure it and so there's
been a push from economic push to sell
vaccines to every arm on in the planet
if not in the country
and that's what we're facing we have
we're facing um a push from above the
government to do this and not from the
science
you know and dr mccary it goes even
beyond that now with these boosters i
mean we're seeing some universities push
boosters
for students it looks like the fda might
approve the pfizer booster for 12 to 15
year olds what science is there behind
that for boosters for young and healthy
people
well the science on boosters for young
and healthy people
points to the recommendation that young
and healthy people should not get a
booster that's where the data lives
right now and that's why the fda's
experts they sit on an advisory
committee called verpack and it's
routinely convened with any
authorization decision the fda does
that's why the advisors voted against
boosters for young people and then the
fda made a second internal push and
simply circumvented those experts they
decided not to convene the meeting and
the rumor is now the new york times is
reporting it as well that they're about
to authorize boosters for 12 through 15
year olds again without convening their
experts that's unconscionable and if we
have any journalism left left in the
united states they should ask why how
how are they getting away with this
i mean dr rich how do you think they're
getting away with this
this has been the modus operandi of the
cdc in the fda for the last two years
that the review committees on on
hydroxychloroquine and rendezvous were
larded with uh pharma people a third 18
out of the 54 in the first committee 11
out of 20 in the second committee that
this has all been orchestrated from the
top of nih and pharma
you know dr mccary
what kind of therapeutics are you saying
is there anything promising that you've
been looking at that we should be
embracing
now that we know that the vaccines
aren't stopping the spread of covid
yeah there's a whole bunch of them and
you know immediately when omicron
emerged our public health officials
immediately started talking to started
talking about additional vaccine
boosters we're now learning 10 weeks
after your booster that immune immunity
goes down to 35 percent the efficacy
goes down to 35 and 45 percent depending
on the vaccine you got there's
fluvoxamine out there it reduced
mortality by 91 it's been fda approved
there's solid randomized controlled
trial data supporting it no data against
it i've never once heard dr fauci or dr
wolinski say the word fluvoxamine many
universities including my own included
on its recommended therapeutics list on
their coveted websites and there's of
course the merck and pfizer pills which
we hear little about but they're ready
to go and they're at pharmacies now
well really looks like our government is
uh failing us miserably dr mccary and dr
rish thank you so much for for joining
me tonight appreciate it hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else